bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats de reportage et d'analyse sur
Public Sénat comme tous les soirs notre
objectif à 18h et 22h c'est deux donner
du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts repousser l'âge de départ en
retraite à 64 ans c'est la proposition
faite par la majorité LR au Sénat cette
réforme est-elle indispensable Emmanuel
Macron va-t-il tenir sa promesse
électorale face à un front uni syndical
et à la menace d'une grave crise sociale
avant de repousser cet âge légal comment
booster l'emploi des seniors en France
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder dans une
minute
connaissez-vous les aides et feux zone à
faible émission qui deviendront
obligatoire dans les villes de plus de
150 000 habitants en 2025 11 métropoles
les ont déjà adopté et veulent interdire
les centres-villes aux véhicules les
plus polluants pour certains comme le LR
Olivier Marnix c'est une inepsie
le fait que on est plus droit de rentrer
quand on est comme moi à bouger
d'Eure-et-Loir de rentrer avec une
voiture au gasoil dans Paris est-ce que
ça va empêcher le réchauffement de la
planète
pour d'autres la pollution tue et c'est
donc un impératif de santé publique ne
ratez pas notre débat dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord les sénateurs LR
qui veulent revenir au centre du jeu
politique avec un âge légal 64 ans et
une réforme des retraites conforme à
leur tradition Flora sauvage
il y a un an déjà la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat adoptait lors
de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale un
amendement pour reporter l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite mais cette fois-ci
le contexte a changé la réforme est à
l'agenda du gouvernement et l'exécutif
ne dispose que d'une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée nationale je pense que cet
amendement non seulement un appel il est
aussi un signal fort disant nous groupes
majoritaires au Sénat voilà ce que nous
pensons c'est un moment une sorte de
d'incitation
au gouvernement d'agir cette fois-ci
l'amendement vise le report de l'âge
légal de départ à 64 ans à partir de la
génération née en 1967 s'il ne prévoit
pas un allongement de la durée de
cotisation pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein il préconise une
accélération de son calendrier en se
basant sur la génération née en 1967 et
non plus 1973 il propose aussi une
convention nationale pendant un an avant
de mettre en place la réforme en réalité
si le gouvernement a reporté cette
réforme c'est qu'il n'a pas su sans
doute mettre autour de la table
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux parce
que c'était là aussi
l'objet d'une réforme ne se fait pas en
la décrétant une critique que refusent
le président du groupe macroniste du
Sénat la majorité sénatoriale essaye
d'inverser les rôles elle voudrait elle
républicain en particulier voudrait
s'attribuer le mérite une réforme des
retraites qui n'ont jamais faite
aujourd'hui le gouvernement veut la
faire la méthode que retient le
gouvernement et qui demandera à Monsieur
Savary de patienter quelques semaines
puisque j'espère que ce texte viendra en
séance viendra devant le Parlement début
du mois de janvier ou février au plus
tard l'exécutif veut aller vite et
Martel quoi qu'en pensent la majorité
sénatoriale la réforme des retraites
doit être opérationnelle d'ici à l'été
et justement René Paul Savary bonsoir
vous êtes présent sur notre plateau
bienvenue sénateur LR de la Marne et
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales j'accueillent également
Catherine tricots bonsoir bienvenue
Catherine directrice de la rue du Regard
Eric Delannoy bon soirée bienvenue le
président fondateur de Tensing conseil
vous êtes économiste et Laetitia cruppa
éditorialiste politique bonsoir Laetitia
bienvenue à vous René Paul Salbris je
commence avec vous évidemment vous avez
porté cette cette amendement en quoi
votre proposition
notamment de faire passer l'âge légal à
64 ans et différente de celle d'Emmanuel
Macron finalement
écoutez moi je suis rapporteur de la
banque vs depuis 2014 depuis 2014 je
présente un amendement pour équilibrer
le système de retraite et si on avait
suivi ces préconisations à cette époque
là je vais vous dire il y aura un
certain nombre de mesures qui seraient
en route et elle serait sûrement moins
radicale que si on attend encore un
certain nombre d'années nous ce qui nous
anime on a toujours la même philosophie
faut faire en sorte que on est un
système moderne de retraite qui
garantissent les pensions des retraités
sinon on fera des retraités pauvres et
puis on sait très bien que d'ailleurs
les pays européens voisins l'ont bien
compris que on a eu un allongement
d'espérance de vie qui a un travail plus
longtemps il faut un équilibre la partie
travail la partie retraite c'est la
raison pour laquelle il nous semble tout
à fait légitime que notre société a
regardé différents
sur l'emploi des seniors d'ailleurs
j'avais commis un rapport sur l'emploi
des seniors parce qu'actuellement c'est
plutôt une variable d'ajuste et dans
notre esprit un chapitre de ce débattre
confiance aux partenaires sociaux c'est
pour ça que je propose ou non la
majorité du Sénat un amendement qui dit
faisons une conférence des partenaires
sociaux on se donne un an de délai parce
que notre but c'est de faire en sorte
qu'on ne travaille pas qu'on ne soit pas
obligé de prendre des mesures pour qu'on
travaille au-delà de 65 ans c'est pour
ça que s'il y a pas des mesures prises
par les partenaires sociaux sur l'emploi
des seniors la prise en charge de la
pénibilité les carrières longues la
solidarité autour de ça les pensions de
version les petites pensions l'égalité
homme-femme etc s'ils n'arrivent pas à
se mettre d'accord nous disons il faudra
prendre des mesures pour l'équilibre et
ces mesures voilà celles que l'on
propose je vous donnerai la part
évidemment plusieurs fois pendant ce
débat Catherine tricot vous dites que
cette réforme pas forcément celle portée
par une et Savary mais le principe aussi
de la de la de la proposition Macron
même si je vois bien les différences
vous dites qu'elle est déconnectée du
monde réel pourquoi dites-vous ça parce
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
véritablement les enjeux et les
mutations que nous sommes en train de
vivre ne portent pas sur le départ de
l'âge à la retraite vous dites que vous
présentez cette amendement depuis 2014
je passe si vous êtes rendu compte que
on a un tout petit peu on est en train
de basculer dans un nouveau monde et
dans lequel les enjeux sont
véritablement des enjeux de
réorientation de notre de notre
production de notre façon de vivre de du
sens de ce que nous faisons et que à mon
avis réduire les débats autour de cette
question de l'âge du départ à la
retraite c'est vraiment passé à travers
les mutations que nous sommes en train
de vivre parce que nous ne sommes pas
c'est pas devant nous que ça se passait
on est en train de muter et on est en
train de raboucir le débat et de coincer
tout le monde parce que en fait pendant
ce temps-là on ne discute pas des
véritables enjeux qui sont ceux de notre
société et ça la crise et ça l'a et ça
ne la met pas sur le bon niveau de
transformation qu'il faut opérer et
j'ajoute à ça que en particulier il y a
une question de transformation du
travail et de donner un sens au travail
que cette proposition ne couvre pas du
tout c'est à dire que les gens ne
veulent pas travailler dans les
conditions d'eau par qui était leur
jusque là trop mal payés trop mal
considéré et puis aussi avec des
transformations du sens du travail on ne
veut plus faire des choses qui n'ont pas
de sens et on est devant des réalités
qui ont beaucoup bougé c'est à dire que
être professeur aujourd'hui à 65 ans
mais je vous souhaite bien du courage ce
n'est pas possible je vous donne la
parole tout de suite mais un mot de
réponse parce que on a vraiment deux
visions complètement différentes de ce
que peut être le partager moi ça m'a pas
échappé tout ça quoi une évolution des
choses c'est pour ça qu'il faut bien le
prendre en compte moi je veux bien une
fois qu'on a dit ça une fois qu'on a dit
ça si on ne bouge pas on va faire partir
déjà à la retraite qui nous qui seront
des retraités pauvres quoi si c'est ça
que l'on souhaite effectivement c'est
une vision c'est la raison pour laquelle
il faut prendre ses responsabiliser
alors pas populaire mais il faut avoir
une vision différente je partage un
point de vue sur l'emploi des seniors
faut vraiment qu'on prenne en compte
maintenant cela il y a une évolution
terrible et Seigneur vous avez vu moi
j'ai fait un rapport senior ça part dans
l'esprit actuel de la société à 45 ans
alors que nous disons misons sur la
formation des personnes un peu plus
âgées pourquoi parce que elle elle
voudront rester jusqu'à un âge défini
l'âge de départ à la retraite vous misez
sur une formation pour un collaborateur
qui va rester dans votre entreprise
cette question là effectivement l'emploi
des seniors et les centrales la
pénibilité c'est évidemment centrale
aussi on va en parler mais je voudrais
vous entendre avec de la noix vous
présentez souvent comme un macroniste de
la première heure est-ce que sur ce
dossier de des retraites vous êtes
encore un macroniste de la sixième année
si je conviens il est vrai qu'on a perdu
un peu de substance dans la réforme qui
est en train d'être présentée moi je
suis assez en phase avec ce qui vient
d'être dit justement ce qui m'avait plus
moi en 2017 c'est que Emmanuel Macron
portait une vision du système de
retraite une vision qui était axée sur
la justice sociale une vision qui était
axée sur la simplification et une vision
qui était axée sur une réforme
systémique
je veux pas polémiquer mais
objectivement celui qui a enfin mis à
mal cette vision et qui en a fait
quelque chose qui n'a pas abouti c'est
Edouard Philippe qui en décembre 2019 a
annoncé qu'on réintroduisait du
paramétrique alors que on n'était pas du
tout sur une réforme paramétrique au
départ puisque les grands équilibres
n'étaient pas mis à mal enfin moi je
voudrais que dire une chose c'est que là
où je rejoins madame c'est que la vie ne
se résume pas à déséquilibre financiers
en fait et que à partir du moment où
depuis 1993 la réforme Balladur on a
fait une succession de réformes qui
bouge les paramètres dans tous les sens
au nom d'un objectif de respecter
l'équilibre financiers on sort du débat
mais quand vous dites ça c'est une
pierre dans le jardin de la de DLR et de
propos mais pas juste pour bien
comprendre non mais pas seulement alors
bien sûr parce que finalement avec cet
amendement là on est sur un même monde
qui est sur la même logique
pardonnez-moi mais sur sur cette logique
que on ne pourrait faire une réforme des
retraites un par un amendement ce qui
est quand même pas le meilleur moyen de
faire une réforme et deux par des
changements de paramètres accélérer un
calendrier etc une réforme systémique il
faut revenir sur une réforme systémique
avec notamment pour reprendre un des
propos qui vient d'être dit un des
sujets qui est dans un angle mort
complet aujourd'hui c'est les retraites
des travailleurs indépendants quand on
parle de travailleurs pauvres quand on
parle de mutation du travail quand on
parle de sortie du salarié on est
aujourd'hui 3 millions de personnes qui
travaillent à leur compte qui a été
d'ailleurs un des un des vecteurs du
plein emploi qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
cette personne qui aujourd'hui travaille
pour eux-mêmes et qui cotise beaucoup
moins que les autres pour leur être
beaucoup moins quasiment deux fois moins
et on se prépare des générations
effectivement de de de de retraités
pauvre non pas si on fait pas la réforme
paramétrique mais si on ne fait pas une
réforme tout court une vraie réforme de
c'est quoi un système de retraite en
France donc il faut une réforme
systémique qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça
pardonnez-moi mais j'ai travaillé
énormément mais le débat il est là
puisque on était associé déjà j'étais
nommé rapporteur à cette époque là j'ai
fait des placements pour voir ce qui se
passait à l'étranger on est en Suède en
Danemark et on s'est rendu compte des
difficultés
à gaz une réforme systémique serait
intéressante si on l'a créé pas si on
remplace un modèle existant or en France
on a un modèle qui existe avec 42
régimes et qui finalement marche pas si
mal que ça a réussi au fil du temps à
faire en sorte que on arrive par rapport
à d'autres pays avoir des niveaux de vie
moyen des retraités qui soient un peu
plus important que ce qui se passe chez
nous voisin et on sait très bien que
avec la démographie actuelle avec la
baisse du nombre de cotisants et avec
également une espérance de vie qui
allonge pas pour tout le monde c'est là
qu'il y a des inégalités c'est là qu'il
faut faire attention et bien notre
système sera déséquilibré et nous aurons
des pouvoirs d'achat qui baisseront
preuve en est ces sont les simulations
du corps c'est pas moi qui invente on
arrive un système très déficitaire ou le
pouvoir d'achat des retraits en 2030 ne
représentera plus que 85 % du pouvoir
moyen d'achat actuellement du salarié
moyen c'est pas acceptable si on ne
prend pas les mesures et de façon
relativement
urgente parce que plus longtemps plus ce
sera brutal et bien nous irons des
générations entières qui pourront pas
bénéficier de leur retraite alors
proposons autre chose mais alors
justement le débat va nous servir à ça
c'est celui-là le corps conseille
d'orientation des retraites c'est ça si
si je ne me trompe pas une réaction
celle du député elle est FID et
Bouches-du-Rhône manuel Bompard c'était
hier dans l'émission audition publique
si le gouvernement s'engage sur cette
voie ou confirme sa volonté de s'engager
sur cette voie il faut qu'il s'attende à
une résistance qui va être une
résistance extrêmement puissante dans la
rue d'abord dans les manifestations aux
côtés des organisations syndicales mais
aussi dans des initiatives qu'on
pourrait prendre nous en tant que
formation politique à l'Assemblée
nationale où on se battra pied à pied
amendement sur un rendement Catherine
tricot c'est quand même une dimension de
l'équation qu'il faut pas négliger quoi
l'opposition syndicale même la CFDT
aujourd'hui par la voie de Laurent
Berger dit pas de report de l'âge légal
donc c'est c'est quoi c'est le ciment
d'ego
mais en tout cas c'est une réforme qui
est cruelle donc les gens vont crier
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez moins
d'un tiers des salariés qui travaillent
jusqu'à l'âge du départ à la retraite ça
veut dire que les deux tiers s'arrêtent
dès 55 ans on commence à avoir une
décroissance très très forte quand vous
êtes au chômage vous avez trois ans de
couverture chômage quelqu'un qui part à
55 ans qui est mis à la retraite à 55
ans ou même 59 59 il a trois ans de
chômage 62 ça veut dire que les deux
dernières ou les trois dernières années
il a rien il n'a pas de revenu du tout
c'est-à-dire que c'est ça que j'appelle
cruel ça veut dire qu'on a des personnes
qui arrivent à l'âge de départ à la
retraite or non seulement ils ont leur
dernière année d'existence où elle ne
touche rien puisqu'elles n'ont plus de
chômage et en plus ça pèse sur leur
pension c'est ça que j'appelle cruel
parce que ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on est en train de repousser l'âge de
départ à la retraite mais on n'est pas
du tout en train de créer les conditions
pour que les gens parce que moi je veux
bien que être cariste à 65 ans je vous
souhaite du bien du courage être
assistante pour dans les hôpitaux
s'occuper des malades à 65 ans c'est
possible non c'est pas possible être
agriculteur à 65 ans c'est possible non
ce n'est pas possible tout donc quels
sont uniquement pour les couches
supérieures mais très supérieurs quelles
sont très favorisées donnez-moi trois
métiers trois métiers que l'on exerce
confortablement valablement à 65 ans les
autres métiers on ne peut plus les faire
à 65 alors un mot de réponse
à quoi à la misère on a compris votre
analyse Catherine tricot je vous propose
de répondre rapidement parce qu'ensuite
on va faire le comparatif européen et
bon comment ils font dans les autres
pays c'est peut-être la question qu'on
peut se poser les autres pays c'est la
première question mais c'est pour ça que
nous proposons une conférence des
partenaires sociaux un an de réflexion
pour justement amener une réponse à tout
cela parce que ce sont des problèmes
réels et il faut les prendre en charge
donc s'il y a pas de réponse on a un
système moi je veux bien qu'on prenne en
compte tout ça mais que proposez-vous
pour faire en sorte que on puisse
assurer les pensions de retraite
je reprends la même seconde je propose à
Quentin calmer de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau bonsoir Quentin bienvenue à vous
alors je l'ai promis donc on le fait
tout de suite comparatif de de ce cet
âge légal de départ à la retraite en
Europe voilà avec une grande diversité
de situations sur le continent le vieux
continent on va voir qu'une poignée de
pays sont alignés sur la légale de 62
ans la France la Suède et la Slovaquie
on y a ajouté la République tchèque ou
là j'ai et 63 ans mais là je peux varier
en fonction du nombre d'enfants élevés
en Estonie l'âge est également fixé à 63
ans le voyant en bleu deuxième groupe de
pays Lettonie Lituanie Hongrie et
Bulgarie qui ont fixé un âge de départ à
64 ans mais la plupart des pays en fait
sont alignés sur 65 ans on compte la
Belgique l'Espagne la Croatie la
Slovénie la Roumanie et les Luxembourg
en Autriche c'est 65 ans pour les hommes
60 ans pour les femmes même chose en
Pologne enfin un groupe de pays se
démarque et à fixé un âge à 66 voire 67
ans l'Allemagne l'Italie l'Irlande le
Portugal le Danemark les Pays-Bas en
Grèce tout dépend du nombre d'années
cotisées à noter ces chiffres vont
changer automatiquement dans 19 pays de
l'Union européenne de manière
progressive au Danemark par exemple
l'âge évoluera progressivement pour
atteindre 69 ans en 2035 autre modèle
les en Slovaquie ou en Italie où l'âge
de départ va évoluer automatiquement à
partir de 2024 en suivant l'espérance de
vie alors l'espérance de vie évidemment
on va en parler tout de suite avec je
vois que ça fait réagirricaux mais nos
invités sur sur ce 69 ans au Danemark
mais il y a aussi donc on l'a commencé à
le faire dans ce débat le lien qui fait
notamment dans un rapport c'est notorial
entre cet âge légal et évidemment le
taux d'emploi des seniors c'est un
hasard monsieur ça varie mais c'est
votre rapport en l'occurrence puisque
vous avez comparé dans ce rapport les
législations sur l'âge de départ et le
taux d'emploi et vous notez vous et les
sénateurs et que les pays où l'âge de
départ à la retraite et le plus élevé et
bien le taux d'emploi des 60 64 ans et
le plus élevé également ça c'est sur les
pays de l'OCDE vous notez dans votre
rapport et vous ajoutez une autre
information concernant la France via un
sondage auprès des actifs qui partent
tout juste à la retraite on note le rôle
prescripteur écrivez vous jouez par les
bandages dans le système de retraite en
clair Thomas les actifs choisissent de
partir à la retraite dès qu'ils ont
atteint
légal qui est donc un marqueur pour les
travailleurs merci beaucoup alors j'ai
bien entendu que vous vouliez réagir les
uns et les autres mais il est quand même
intéressant Eric Delannoy se comparatif
européen et notamment moi je reviens sur
cette idée de finalement Liége de la
retraite à l'espérance de vie est-ce que
c'est une idée totalement absurde est-ce
que nos certains nos voisins sont tombés
sur la tête ou finalement ce n'est pas
du bon sens d'abord certains de enfin
comme vous dites les voisins ont
peut-être eu le plus de courage que nous
avant faire les bonnes réformes la Suède
on est un très bon exemple enfin quand
je rencontre Monsieur Bompard faut quand
même avoir en tête une chose c'est qu'il
y a une seule certitude dans la réforme
des retraites c'est que depuis qu'on
fait des réformes depuis 93 il y en a
une dizaine les syndicats ont été
systématiquement contre en étant
systématiquement compte si on n'avait
pas mis en oeuvre ce qui a été mis en
oeuvre depuis 93 on serait dans le mur
donc en étant systématiquement contre on
va nulle part ça quand même un premier
point dans les autres pays on a fait on
a eu le courage de faire des réformes
des réformes assez ambitieuses la Suède
on est en un très bon exemple donc oui
évidemment qu'il faut lier ça
l'espérance de vie mais si on le lit à
l'espérance de vie il faut le lier
complètement et on rejoint la pénibilité
parce que l'espérance de vie c'est une
chose elle a pris 10 ans depuis une
vingtaine une trentaine d'années mais
l'écart entre l'espérance de vie d'un
cadre et l'espérance d'un ouvrier est
elle-même de 10 ans et ça c'est dans
quel état
donc on ne peut être que sensible au
fait que il faut prendre en compte la
pénibilité pour que les métiers
difficiles et c'est là où on se dit que
la vie n'est pas un équilibre financier
il faut prendre en compte les situations
réelles pour avoir une réforme
systémique moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec le fait que on puisse dire
qu'aujourd'hui le système de retraite
fonctionne bien c'est un système qui n'a
pas de justice sociale c'est un système
qui ne facilite pas la mobilité entre
les emplois qui est en train d'augmenter
c'est un système qui est ultra compliqué
qui a des coups de gestion deux fois
supérieur au coup de gestion de la
retraite européenne on pourrait faire
des économies de 3 milliards par an en
le réformant sur un mode systémique donc
ce n'est pas vrai de dire que c'est un
système qui marche bien et par ailleurs
alors qu'il y a eu un travail de 2 à 3
ans effectivement avec Monsieur Delevoye
où il y a eu un rapport énorme qui n'a
pas été exploité c'est ça qui est
incroyable une somme de choses qui ont
été faites avec
les corps de métier qui ont été examinés
toutes les difficultés alors
effectivement c'est compliqué mais c'est
là que les transitions sont intenses la
pénibilité parce que exactement parfait
on se demande si vraiment c'est pénible
ou pas ce n'est pas une exactement ce
n'est pas un venir ce n'est pas une
convention ce n'est pas une convention
annuelle enfin qui va durer un an qui va
résoudre les problèmes alors que on n'a
pas fait quoi que ce soit sur un travail
de fond qui était fait en trois ans et
sur les régions spéciaux enfin on se
plaint qu'aujourd'hui le nombre de
cotisants par par retraité est en train
diminuer drastiquement je rappelle qu'à
la RATP on a 0,8 cotisants pour un
retraité ça coûte 800 millions à la
collectivité donc si on ne met pas en
place quelque chose qui met fin à ces
systèmes totalement uniques qui
d'ailleurs n'est pas vrai pour les
autres entreprises de transport qui sont
pas sous l'origine de la RATP un
conducteur lui RATP peut partir à 52 ans
il part à 55 à un conducteur de de
transport à Bordeaux dans une société
privée à Bordeaux il part comme les
autres où est le problème de d'aligner
ces régimes spéciaux qui sont un
véritable scandale français mais on n'a
pas eu le courage de mettre en œuvre le
étant 1995 un renoncement à la réforme
parce que les syndicats sont partis
dehors allez chapitres régimes spéciaux
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Catherine
tricot on peut dire effectivement qu'il
y a des régimes spéciaux qui avaient un
sens hier il y a 20 30 40 ans et qui
sont
totalement dépassés aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être d'autres métiers d'ailleurs
qui pourraient en bénéficier alors bon
je pense qu'on peut rentrer dans cette
discussion je voulais juste faire une
remarque sur ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure monsieur vous disiez que en
France on arrivait à faire un taux de
recouvrement des retraites qui étaient
un peu meilleur que dans le reste de
l'Europe peut-être que c'est parce que
justement l'âge de départ à la retraite
et 62 ans et qu'on a pas toute cette
dégradation de la fin de vie de la fin
de carrière qui fait qu'on a des
ressources
est-ce que vous voulez défendre est-ce
que est-ce que on y touche pas comme un
totem non non moi je pense qu'on peut y
toucher au régime spéciaux le sel la
seule question que moi je voudrais poser
c'est quels sont les métiers je repose
la question quelles sont les métiers que
véritablement on pense qu'il est
possible d'exercer à 65 ans est-ce
qu'une institutrice peut être
institutrice jusqu'à 65 ans
je voudrais savoir en dehors de
sénateurs et journalistes
ce qui nous réunit quels sont les
caricatures
des instituteurs qui sont très heureux
de leur métier et qui veulent l'exercer
à jusqu'à 65 ans vous êtes dans un
amalgame qui est caricatural pardon 80
il y a évidemment des instituteurs qui
sont épuisés à 55 ans et qui n'ont pas
bien sûr 65 ans quand vous avez 30
enfants dans une classe mais c'est
presque la conception du travail c'est
pour ça que c'est on est au cœur du bas
le travail forcément ça dégrade c'est ce
que moi non pas tout à fait c'est pas ce
que je pense parce qu'on peut grandir
aussi à tout à fait donc je suis pas je
suis pas contre le travail ce que je
pensais que il y a une transformation du
travail et que l'autre question à propos
de la richesse au fond comment on paye
les richesses on paye les richesses on
paye les retraites avec la richesse que
l'on produit notre problème c'est pas
d'avoir des métiers de plus en plus
dégradés et qui produisent de moins en
moins de valeur mais plutôt d'avoir des
métiers qui sont en phase avec les
besoins d'aujourd'hui et qui crée de la
valeur notre pays est en train de perdre
ses capacités productives contemporaines
de valeur ajoutée donc notre problème
n'est pas d'aller tirer jusqu'à la
dernière corde les dernières forces des
salariés mais d'essayer de retrouver des
métiers qui font sens et qui produisent
et ensuite Eric de Lana qui voulait
intervenir je crois qu'il faut beaucoup
d'humilité dans l'approche moi je
croisais un maçon l'autre jour je dis je
connaissais pas qu'est-ce que vous
faites je suis maçon vous êtes un
multiple pénible ah il dit non le gars
il a il a 60 plus de 60 ans elle me dit
non quand on aime son métier c'est pas
un métier pénible vous voyez que quoi
les carrières longues
pour vous dire que il faut beaucoup
d'humilité dans l'approche quand vous
prenez les carrières longues 30% des
carrières longues rentre dans un
dispositif cumule emploi retraite il
faut en prendre connaissance de tout ça
il y a rien de pire on la verrait dans
notre rapport sur l'emploi que de mettre
un seigneur dehors le pire qu'il faut
faire c'est le faire sortir du travail
par mesure telles qu'on les propose à
travers du chômage etc là vous le mettez
et c'est le médecin qui parle dans des
situations beaucoup plus difficiles que
ce qui peut être proposé mais je
voudrais revenir
social de la retraite par exemple
inutilité redoutable pour faire très
attention à cela quand même c'est pour
ça qu'il faut vraiment un oeil différent
sur l'emploi des seniors pour faire en
sorte qu'on ne puisse leur proposer des
solutions pour qu'ils arrivent et pas
forcément le métier qu'ils ont fait mais
le maçon il peut enseigner un autre et
là-dessus il y a des pistes simplement
par rapport aux étrangers
[Musique]
ce sont des régimes complémentaires par
capitalisation grand deux le niveau de
vie est très inférieur grand trois la
Suède le modèle qui fait rêver ils sont
en train de reculer l'âge légal qui
était porté à 67 ans et qui est à 65 ans
qui va être à 67 et ils sont les
retraités retravaillent parce que ils
n'ont pas ils n'ont pas un suffisant
donc vaut peut-être mieux parfois
travailler un petit peu plus longtemps
quand on a la soixantaine que t'aide
obligé de travailler quand vous avez 70
ans c'est une vraie question d'aller à
contre-courant d'une partie de l'Europe
oui intervenir oui je voulais intervenir
parce que le débat qu'on a là traduit la
difficulté à évaluer les notions de
pénibilité qui sont des notions très
subjectives la seule objectivité que moi
je peux y mettre dans ce débat c'est
quand on le regarde les autres pays
européens ils travaillent plus que nous
et j'ai pas le sentiment que les
personnes sont plus malheureuses que
nous donc la France je vous rappelle
dans le l'indice du bonheur est très
très loin des pays qui partent en 13 à
65 ans donc moi l'idée que le travail
casse qui est une une ancienne qu'on
entend en permanence notamment dans à
l'extrême gauche c'est insupportable et
je pense qu'en ratant une réforme peu
cassée mais c'est pas une généralité
bien évidemment on ne peut pas prendre
une réforme de retrait sur le fait que
le travail casse on doit prendre une
réforme de retraite sur qu'est-ce qu'il
dit de la solidarité nationale qu'est-ce
qu'il dit de la surdité
interagiteérationnelle qu'est-ce qu'il
dit pourquoi on fait pas versus la
répartition parce qu'on a une conception
de la solidarité de la justice sociale
qui doit être réaffirmée mais par
prendre le régime des retraites sur
l'angle négatif de la dévalorisation du
travail c'est parfaitement insupportable
parce que ça ne met pas en
prédisposition positive le fait qu'on
regarde de manière le plus objectif
possible ce qui est effectivement la
pénibilité de chacun des métiers et on
ne peut pas dire que pour tous les
métiers tous les métiers cassent moi
j'ai un frère qui est infirmier il a pas
l'intention de partir en retraite il
adore son métier et pourtant le métier
d'affirmer est un métier difficile je
suis d'accord
obligé de partir à 62 mais oui mais non
mais le problème c'est qu'il faut
pouvoir partir
là ce qu'on est en train de faire c'est
qu'on est en train d'empêcher les gens
de partir et encore une fois on les
empêche de partir avec des conditions de
survie qui sont catastrophiques comment
voulez-vous passer de 1/3 aujourd'hui
des gens qui vont jusqu'à l'âge de
départ de la retraite on emploie à une
solution où tout le monde va jusqu'à
l'emploi mais non mais
commençons alors commençons par ça
comment mais commençons commençons
commençons par commençons par ça par
créer des conditions pour que les gens
puissent rester dans l'emploi et que ces
conditions-là elles sont pas mineurs
c'est à dire c'est des questions qui ont
avoir avec l'organisation du travail le
nombre de gens qui souffrent d'avoir un
travail qui a perdu du sens parce qu'il
s'est bureaucratisé parce qu'il est
parce qu'il est exercé dans des
conditions difficiles parce que quand on
vieillit on ne vieillit pas puisque vous
êtes médecin vous le savez on ne vit les
logements de la vie ce n'est pas un
allongement de la vie en bonne santé
cette allongement là il sait voilà donc
là en bonne santé il reste autour de 65
ans donc pouvoir partir avant d'être
simplement par
qui vont choisir si on maintient ou pas
les résultats spéciaux juste pour bien
comprendre moi je ne non pas ça alors je
veux voir les critères de pénibilité
pour
le répéter alors le régime particulier
d'accord mais moi je ne mets pas en
cause les résines spéciaux pourquoi
j'aimais pas en cause et vous parler des
avantages qu'ils ont c'est parce que ça
faisait partie de leur statut voyez-vous
quand ils ont été embauchés ils avaient
à moindre salaire mais ils travaillent
par terre avant voilà et puis ils
avaient certaines conditions qui étaient
plus pénibles simplement ils ont des
maintenant ils ont des retraites en
vieux qui fait des envieux par rapport
aux autres et qu'est-ce qu'on procose on
dit ah ben il faut supprimer les régimes
spéciaux moi je serai plutôt à dire
pourquoi les retraités il n'iraient pas
avoir un certain nombre d'avantages qui
ont eu certains un certain moment ça
veut dire que la conception la
conception concerta c'est de faire des
retraités pauvres et on prend pas de
mesure que la conception qui nous anime
c'est de faire des retraités qui
puissent avoir un pouvoir d'achat et
vivre ensemble aller plutôt s'aligner
sur sa ligne sur la mais faire en sorte
de tirer vers le haut et tirer vers le
haut ça veut dire que tout le monde aura
un effort collectif à faire et notamment
à travers cette emploi ou le maintien de
l'emploi dans les seniors dans des
conditions
est-ce qu'on en a les moyens non mais
enfin je veux dire il y a les chiffres
sont là enfin la SNCF c'est 3 milliards
et demi que l'État remet pour équilibrer
lesquels maintenant
pour les nouveaux arrivants donc ça va
ça va mettre 20 ans à se mettre en place
donc la RATP c'est exactement le même
problème donc nous n'avons pas les
moyens de faire en sorte que finalement
tous les retraités vivent très très bien
je suis désolé aujourd'hui mais oui ce
qu'il faut mais il faut faire une vraie
réforme faut pas faire une réforme
paramétrique une vraie réforme qui va
être sur par exemple plus ceux qui
connaissent pardon ceux qui gagnent le
plus de rogne un peu plus sur le salaire
parce que finalement y compris dans le
secteur privé les écarts de salaire sont
pour certaines pour certains absolument
scandaleux avec ce qu'il cotise on les
inégalités sociales dans le système de
retraite la réforme systémique elle doit
rééquilibrer tout ça en relevant les
petites retraites et en baissant les
grandes nous avons les retraites les
mieux payées d'Europe ce n'est pas
possible de tenir ça avec les systèmes
de enfin je veux pas revenir sur les
problématiques de de qu'on y a de mais
il y a des retraits
il y a de la passion sur ce plateau
c'est bien Catherine tricot moi ce que
je pense aussi c'est qu'un impensé dans
tout ça c'est au fond quelle masse
d'argent nous consacrons en retraite on
se dit 14% du PIB et on en bouge pas ben
moi je regrette mais je compte il y a
plus de retraités je ne vois pas
pourquoi ce chiffre de 14% ne pourrait
pas bouger on peut le faire le ça peut
faire l'objet d'une discussion et donc
je dis deux choses c'est un pour ça ça
peut il peut y avoir une augmentation du
PIB c'est ce que je plais depuis tout à
l'heure en disant il faut réfléchir sur
un travail qui crée de la valeur et pas
cher et pas chercher à faire du travail
qui n'a pas de valeur premier point non
non le travail qui crée de la valeur
c'est un travail qui est qui produit de
la valeur et pas le type qu'on tire
jusqu'au bout allez allez tu vas bien
quand même encore travailler 3 mois de
plus premier point deuxième point donc
on peut créer à payer on peut augmenter
le PIB par un nouvel par une approche
différente de la richesse nationale
deuxièmement on peut créer plus de
pourcentage on peut consacrer plus de
pourcentage du PIB au retraite et on
peut discuter de la part des cotisations
consacrer aux retraites tout ça ce sont
des impensés la seule chose que l'on dit
c'est 14% on bouge plus et donc on
divise le gagnant et on le répartie
autrement je reprends la main quel
quelques secondes parce qu'on va ouvrir
un chapitre peut-être un petit peu plus
politique dans ce débat on reviendra sur
les questions de d'emploi des seniors
pour pour conclure on va se poser la
question de la l'éventuelle convergence
entre LR et le gouvernement sur cette
réforme mais d'abord Laetitia zoom sur
celui qui a apporté son soutien à
Emmanuel Macron sur cette réforme des
retraites c'était Edouard Philippe il a
même voulu aller plus loin que le
président et là il y a un risque
politique oui il a pris un risque et la
preuve c'est que quand on regarde les
derniers sondages je peux vous en poser
un comme ça c'est le dernier et Lab pour
les échos Radio Classique on voit
qu'Edouard Philippe perd 6 points en un
mois et 9 points en deux mois c'est le
chouchou des Français je vous rappelle
leur Philippe or il y a un mois c'est là
où précisément là où il est vraiment il
dévisse c'est là où on le voit en une je
ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu mais c'est
une du Parisien avec une la base choc il
dit sur les retraites il faut bouger
c'était le samedi 8 octobre et surtout
des chiffres chocs 65 voire 67 ans donc
le timing il a bien été choisi avec
minutie évidemment un par Édouard
Philippe et son équipe parce qu'on est
trois jours après l'intervention
d'Olivier du socle le ministre du
Travail qui ouvre la grande concertation
sur cette réforme des retraites donc oui
Edouard Philippe apporte son soutien on
peut dire Emmanuel Macron mais surtout
se réinvite dans le débat politique et
rappel dans l'interview de parisien que
il n'a pas changé sa ligne qu'il ne la
changera pas et que déjà il y a un an il
était pour ce report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 65 voire 67 mais
donc on l'a dit prend des risques hyper
en popularité oui mais il était le
premier ministre vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur pendant le premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron à avoir tenté de mener
cette réforme elle a été avortée à cause
de l'épidémie de covid et déjà à
l'époque il était quand même confronté à
une levée de bouclier un 61% des
Français étaient pas convaincus par
cette réforme je vous rappelle aussi
qu'Edouard Philippe est quand même
l'apôtre d'Alain Juppé qui vous l'avez
rappelé aussi à Dieu finalement reculer
au bout de 27 jours de manifestations de
blocage de la France en 1995 donc on
peut être à peu près certain d'une chose
c'est qu'il sait que cette mesure est un
populaire et que c'est un sujet
finalement viscéral presque pour les
Français on l'a vu est-ce que ça veut
dire que pour vous cette prise de
position d'Édouard Philippe elle
pourrait ne pas lui être préjudiciable
alors là on se projette en cas de
candidature à la prochaine
présidentielle c'est mon avis parce que
finalement il laisse Emmanuel Macron et
Elisabeth borne essuyer les plâtres
puisque malgré bon la popularité de
cette réforme l'exécutif l'annonce pour
2023 donc si vous voulez ce sera fait et
puis finalement Édouard Philippe
continue de développer son argumentaire
qui est rodé depuis plusieurs mois bien
sûr qui rappelle le cas de l'Italie
d'Allemagne qui sont sur 67 ans et aussi
il dit que c'est une piste pour lutter
contre l'endettement colossal de la
France la dette publique c'est
l'obsession d'Édouard Philippe donc il
laisse Emmanuel Macron à la manœuvre
pour mieux en profiter après c'est ça
il y a une petite phrase qui a retenu
mon attention à mon avis elle a été
travaillée cette phrase Édouard Philippe
dit mon objectif n'est pas de plaider
pour la solution la plus dure afin
d'emmerder le monde ce mot emmerdé il a
déjà été utilisé par Emmanuel Macron
voilà donc c'est malin c'est placé dans
une phrase comme ça à contre-pied du
président pourquoi pour mettre l'opinion
publique cette fois-ci de son côté c'est
loin d'être gagné pour le moment mais
nous sommes qu'en 2022 réforme
impopulaire un épaule Savary malgré tout
vous continuez à nez après année c'est
ce que vous nous avez expliqué de dire
il faut la faire si je suis un peu
cynique est-ce que c'est pas aussi un
piège vis-à-vis Emmanuel Macron qui
enfin c'est une façon de le pousser à
faire cette réforme à populaire
effectivement ce que dit c'est lui qui
de toute façon sera en première ligne
face à la rue Emmanuel
macronibiliser bien entendu on a nos
convictions on reste fidèles à nos
convictions parce que nous pensons
surtout que outre l'emploi des signaux
on a parlé qu'il faut faire confiance
aux partenaires sociaux c'est la grande
différence avec ce que propose Emmanuel
Macron puisque visiblement il fait pas
confiance il y a qu'à voir le
recouvrement des cotisations URSSAF par
la jkco par l'URSSAF qui a été amendé
par le Sénat supprimer par le Sénat donc
il y a pas de confiance vis-à-vis des
partenaires sociaux alors que nous ne
vous en confiance pourquoi ne vous en
confiance parce que ceux qui connaissent
au mieux les situations des des
travailleurs et que d'autre part ils ont
déjà fait preuve de responsabilité dans
un certain nombre de régimes ils ont
surprend leur
responsabilité et puis que quand les
régimes de retraite sont gérés par les
partenaires sociaux ils génèrent des
réserves quand ils sont gérés par l'État
ils génèrent des déficits c'est pour ça
que je ne suis pas favorable à une
interprétisation telle que proposée dans
la réforme universelle et puis
deuxièmement nous on veut pas travailler
jusque 65 ans mais vous et si on prend
pas nos responsabilités voilà on va
aboutir à quelque chose de
contre-productif parce que à force de ne
pas prendre les décisions et ben on sera
amené à faire comme les autres pays que
vous avez signalé autour de nous 65 66
ans en faisant des retraités pauvres
c'est pas notre conception de la société
c'est pour accepter je finis simplement
il faut prendre ses responsabilités il y
a des fois faut savoir peut-être pas
être populaire intenter mais en vous
remerciant plus tard parce qu'on dira
finalement heureusement qu'il y a eu des
gens courageux preuve en est c'est que
d'autres ont pris des réformes et
aujourd'hui on dit même système il tient
grâce à des formes à un moment de
Balladur grâce à la réforme Touraine qui
va s'appliquer et la réforme Touraine
elle a poussé à 43 ans on pousse pas
plus 43 ans la nuitée quoi on ne dit pas
il faut travailler 44 ans nous on dit 4
ans 43 ans de nuit politique
et au fond du trou c'est peut-être parce
que s'il y a eu cette réforme
je crois que je crois que les le le la
réforme Touraine fait partie des
marqueurs qui ont profondément dégradé
le Parti socialiste dans l'opinion de
gauche et chez les salariés c'est une
question pourquoi cette réforme est
aussi impopulaire est-ce que chaque
Français peut vraiment de façon
individuelle moi j'aimerais bien avoir
chaque citoyen je suis prête à donner
mon temps pour ça et avec il m'explique
pourquoi il est contre voilà est-ce
qu'il y a une pédagogie suffisante
rapidement
avec l'application des réformes prises
avant les gens vont partir à leur taux
plein ils sont déjà aujourd'hui près de
63 ans si on retire les carrières
longues et ils vont naturellement dans
les années qui viennent dès 2026 est à
63 64 ans simplement
on se cache les yeux parce que les gens
partent au taux plein avec une retraite
conséquente donc naturellement ils vont
à ça
l'acceptabilité ou de la popularité de
cette de cette réforme réagir sur je
trouve qu'il y a un argument un peu
spécieux sur non confiant dans les
partenaires sociaux je voudrais juste te
rappeler que la réforme systémique de
2017 s'appuyait sur un copier-coller
d'agirco qui est géré par les
partenaires sociaux donc de dire que il
ne faisait pas confiance le partenaire
sociaux je trouve ça un peu bizarre mais
bah oui enfin la réforme qui devait être
systémique elle s'appuyer exactement sur
les modes de fonctionnement de l'agir
Carco qui est géré par les partenaires
sociaux et qui est très bien géré par
les partenaires sociaux
par point qui
ressentent un point légère Carco et le
seul régime de retraite aujourd'hui
gérant par point donc ça va pas rentrer
dans le détail parce que c'est sans
doute un peu trop complexité pourquoi
est-ce que ça pose une question il y a
un risque quand même de d'unité
syndicale de crise sociale de
manifestation annoncée de grève
annoncées mais parce que à partir du
moment où on ne voit ça que comme un
problématique d'équilibre financier les
gens les citoyens ne perçoivent ça comme
un effort et ne perçoivent pas comme
quelque chose qui va dire encore une
fois un récit sur la solidarité
nationale et le lien intergénérationnel
on ne parle pas de du travail quand on
parle de la réforme de retraite on parle
de oulala on va travailler plus et donc
on va on va gagner moins plus le fait
qu'il y a une défiance dans le politique
sur la capacité dans le temps à faire
des des trouver des solutions à trouver
des solutions
qui vont jusqu'à non seulement j'en
connais beaucoup mais même
je connais également
de recrutement pas du tout il se trouve
que moi j'ai dans mon tiers des Français
qui vont jusqu'à l'âge de là
il se trouve
et puis il y a tous ceux qui font un
autre métier une fois qu'ils sont en
retraite il y en a énormément notamment
des métiers de bénévoles dans les
associations je reprends la main parce
que là c'est un peu pardon Catherine
tricot c'est un peu la cacophonie et
finalement ce qui est derrière votre
intervention c'est aussi la question de
l'emploi des seniors dont on a déjà
parlé dans ce débat mais je voudrais
apporter ma petite pierre à ce débat
avec un comparatif là aussi sur le taux
d'emploi des seniors avec les autres
pays d'Europe et notamment les pays du
nord de l'Europe qui domine de très loin
ce classement puisqu'on est à autour de
80 plus de 80 % en Islande 76% en Suède
74% en Norvège 72%, au Danemark ensuite
on va trouver la Suisse l'Allemagne qui
est au-delà des 71 les Pays-Bas aussi au
delà des 71 et puis on baisse un peu le
Portugal 63 et on trouve la France à un
peu moins de 56 55,9% pour un faux la
moyenne européenne c'est 60,5% de taux
d'emploi des seniors on est donc un peu
en dessous le Seigneur c'était 55 soit
en France
mais bon on va rester sur ce c'est au
stade qui fait cette alors c'est ce que
vous proposez j'ai bien lu votre
proposition votre abonnement ça démarre
par un an de concertation et trouver
cette solution parce que effectivement
ça a pas beaucoup de sens de dire on va
prolonger là je la retraite si on est un
taux d'emploi des seniors qui reste
aussi bas alors qu'est-ce que là ce
serait inhumain oui mais alors qu'est-ce
que vous proposez des mesures concrètes
pour améliorer cette statistique et
écouter il y a un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont actuellement
incitatives à partir plus tôt et les
entreprises savent s'en servir elles ont
des difficultés à 60 ans on est où là il
nous coûte cher voilà donc il faut
revoir l’œil différent faire nous on
avait proposé qui est à un certain
moment de la carrière et ça tombe bien
le ministre vient de le proposer aussi
des 45 ans madame parce que je suis
désolé c'est pas moi qui est j'ai fait
ce triste constat d'apprendre que
c'était à 45 ans
on a fait un débat complet sur l'emploi
des seniors c'était le constat c'est là
qu'il faut commencer à voir envisager il
faut qu'il y ait une discussion entre le
collaborateur et son et son employeur
parce que voir comment chacun peut
retrouver mieux vivre au sein de
l'entreprise notamment pour ceux qui
sont salariés ou autre et prendre en
compte des difficultés de certains mais
ça ça peut se faire on n'est pas dans un
monde figé c'est pas pour autant qu'il
faut tout changer à vouloir tout changer
on ne change rien en France c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai vraiment
favorable plutôt à des mesures
paramétriques que des mesures
systémiques preuve en est ça n'a pas
abouti ça pourra jamais aboutir mais là
on peut trouver on peut trouver allez
avec les partenaires de votre expertise
sur la question de l'emploi des seniors
de formation dans cette aujourd'hui il y
a plus de formation proposée
mais il est vrai que les quand on n'a
pas eu un poste de responsabilité à 45
ans on en aura jamais donc c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui on a un enjeu majeur de
transmission transmission des
savoir-faire faire beaucoup il y a une
problématique autour de la formation
professionnelle tout au long de la vie
les seniors sont les mieux placés pour
faire cette transmission pourquoi
pourquoi ne mettons pas en place sur des
métiers notamment difficiles dans lequel
il y a des transmissions de savoir-faire
je pense à un maçon par exemple qui est
quand même un métier qui est quand même
pas facile transmettre le métier de
maçon c'est différent de pratiquer le
métier de maçon et pourtant c'est tout
aussi clé dans le fait de pouvoir avoir
demain des maçons donc et on a des
aspects de reclassement qui pourraient
ensuite même jouer en faveur des régimes
spéciaux je me souviens j'étais sur un
plateau ici avec quelqu'un qui qui était
à l'Opéra de Paris l'Opéra de Paris
c'est clair que après 40 ans ou 35 ans
c'est terminé et ben il faut prévoir un
reclassement reclassement et formation
un dernier mot pardon nous interrompre
mais il nous reste une minute Catherine
tricot parce que c'est peut-être
là-dessus qu'on va vous mettre d'accord
vous dites commençons par là ben oui
commençons par ça puisque si vous dites
qu'on peut que on utilise des maçons
pour faire pour former d'autres maçons
mais c'est très bien commençons par ça
c'est-à-dire il faut si vous comprenez
bien que c'est pas dans l'entreprise
c'est pas le maçon de la petite
entreprise qui va former l'autre maçon
parce que la petite entreprise ça peut
pas payer le jeune maçon et le vieux
maçon qui forment le jeu de maçon donc
ça veut dire des écoles de formation
mais ça qu'on le fasse et si on pense
que les formateurs des jeunes maçons ils
vont y arriver à 55 ans 60 ans 62 ans
pour commencer une grande carrière de
formation de formateurs de maçon je
crois qu'on se trompe je pense que ce
n'est pas vrai finalement ça marche pas
non plus mais non ce que je veux dire
mais non je dis pas qu'on touche à rien
ce que je dis c'est qu'on peut
transformer des métiers je pense qu'il y
a des choses qui peuvent se faire mais
nous racontons pas que les maçons vont
pouvoir rester massons non ça je ne
crois pas il faut leur permettre de
partir plus tôt si à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant et enflammé je vous dis à
bientôt évidemment dans ce sens